we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P on the bonus show
yesterday I told stories about uh my
flights out and back from California I
also talked about of the homeless
problem in San Francisco in fact I I
didn't criticize the homeless people I
said San Francisco didn't cause
homelessness the Eggman apparently
didn't like what I had to say listen to
this
hey Dave
um just a little bit disappointed in how
you describe the homeless people sorry
these and the camps and stuff that you
saw while out Visiting San Francisco
um personally when I see stuff like that
I go over and interact with people I
meet them I talk to them okay I drove by
the encampments uh on the way to an
event I'm sorry Eggman I didn't stop to
talk to people at the encampment I I'm
sorry I didn't do it you're right get
high with them I buy them some food I
hang out maybe they buy me some food
maybe they get me high
um so those are just people that I want
to meet and talk to a lot more than
people on an airplane stuffing 50 bags
in an overhead I I was not stuffing 50
bags in an overhead uh I I brought on a
rollerboard and a personal item my
girlfriend brought on a rollerboard and
a personal item and then we had the
foldable baby stroller which folds right
into the overhead and then we had a
diaper bag okay there was nothing crazy
going on Greg and a kid around I mean
look I would love to hang out with you
but I would much more like to hang out
with somebody living in an RV in San
Francisco all right well I'm sorry
Eggman go and drive to San Francisco and
hang out at the RV I'm sorry I failed
the Eggman when it came to the
encampments all right we've got a great
bonus show for you today I won't even
tell you what's on it because I'm
running so behind but it's a great bonus
show I encourage you to check it out